mes amis c'est la première fois que le
conseil national se réunit depuis les
primaires et ça fait chaud au coeur
parce que moi j'aime ces moments où on
vous retrouve et c'est d'abord vers vous
que je veux me tourner vous qui êtes les
forces vives de notre famille politique
il est à la mode chez certains de
dénigrer les partis politiques
eh bien nous nous croyons exactement l
inverse sans vous rien n'aurait été
possible
la réussite de la primaire c'est vous la
tenue des bureaux de vote c'est vous les
militants de terrain c'est vous
l'engagement des bénévoles c'est vous et
la victoire de françois fillon ce sera
vous vous êtes les militants de notre
famille politique et je suis fier
terrible égard
on est en 2017 ouf ça y est on y est
presque cinq ans mais qu'est ce que ça
nous a semblé long cinq ans de
socialisme et nous avons enfin l'espoir
de nous en débarrasser
alors croyez moi la victoire personne
n'a l'intention de la laisser passer
françois la france a besoin de ta
victoire
elle a besoin de ta victoire
parce qu'il faut mettre fin à la
déconstruction du pays par la gauche
ne vous y trompez pas ils appliquent une
vraie idéologie de déconstruction une
idéologie de déconstruction comme
taubira expliqué que la justice ne doit
pas punir une idéologie de
déconstruction quand najat vallaud
belkacem supprime l'enseignement de
l'histoire une idéologie de
déconstruction comme manuel valls encore
maintenant défend le rsa pour les jeunes
ils ne font pas d'erreurs
il applique une idéologie cette
idéologie de la déconstruction seyssel
mes amis qui a battu les frontières
c'est celle qui déteste la famille c'est
celle qui refuse l'autorité c'est celle
qui nourrit le communautarisme c'est
celle qui veut un monde sans identité et
s'enracine nous nous ne voulons pas de
ce monde et nous réclamant de pouvoir
transmettre à nos enfants nos valeurs
alors pour gagner il faut trois
conditions la première condition c'est
l'unité
j'ai soutenu nicolas sarkozy
vous me connaissez vous me connaissez je
ne renie jamais mes engagements je n'ai
pas l'habitude de dire les choses à
moitié
je reste fidèle à ses valeurs je
n'oublie pas ce qu'il a apporté à notre
famille politique est comme nous tous
j'ai été touché par sa dignité
le soir du premier tour quand il a
trouvé les mots pour apporter son
soutien c'était son honneur nous
n'oublions pas nicolas tu as causé
et aujourd'hui françois nous avons tous
le devoir du rassemblement nous voyons
bien ce que certains voudraient écrire
depuis quelques jours alors que ce matin
les choses soient claires françois tu as
tout notre soutien et nous serons tous à
tes côtés deux essais non françois
l'unité ce n'est pas l'uniformité
tu n'as pas besoin de clown autour de
toi tu n'as pas besoin de courtisans il
faut des paroles fortes et des
convictions clair philippe seguin
n'était pas saxe irak et il s'est battu
pour sa victoire en 1995
tu n'es pas nicolas sarkozy et tu t'es
battu pour sa victoire en 2007
c'est cette diversité qui fera notre
force
rassembler et déterminé nous irons
chercher cette victoire
en 2017
platt seconde condition c'est d'assumer
nos convictions
toutes nos convictions on arrête de
s'excuser d'être de droite françois ton
succès à la primaire la montre et tu as
compris que les français ne demandait
pas l'immobilisme
ils veulent le changement ils ne veulent
pas une droite qui en disent moins ils
veulent une droite qui en fasse plus ils
ne veulent pas monsieur le premier
ministre edouard balladur que nous avons
l'honneur et le plaisir d'accueillir
merci de votre présence comme à chaque
fois à nos côtés merci monsieur le
premier ministre
ils ne veulent pas mais a mis une droite
tian 10 - ils veulent une droite qui en
fasse plus ils ne veulent pas renoncer à
leur valeur ils attendent des politiques
qu'ils ont une colonne vertébrale
nous sommes de droite et nous sommes
fiers de nos valeurs et la gauche ne
nous donne plus de sens en 2017 ce n'est
plus la cgt qui dictera ses volontés au
pays et il faudra avoir le courage de
revenir sur toutes ces lois socialistes
et je pense évidemment à la loi taubira
alors oui françois tu as raison de dire
qu'il faudra des économies sur la
dépense publique
tu as raison de dire qu'il y aura demain
moins de fonctionnaires et oui il faudra
mener les réformes indispensables a
commencé par une vraie réforme du régime
de retraite parce que la seule réforme
qui vaille c'est celle qui mettra à
égalité les retraites du public et du
privé et qui supprimera la totalité des
régimes spéciaux
oui oui c'est ce courage
qu'attendent les français et ce sont ces
efforts qu'ils sont prêts à soutenir
parce que ces efforts
ce sont des efforts de justice vous avez
vu la gauche
ils ont supprimé les heures
supplémentaires
ils veulent le rsa jeunes tout en
enlevant les bourses au mérite et
maintenant leur dernière trouvaille
c'est le revenu universel superbe
invention tamponné pur produit
socialiste gagner plus
en ne faisant arrêts
et bien pour nous le travail et l'effort
ce ne sont pas des gros mots alors oui
nous devons parler à la france qui
travaille la droite à laquelle nous
croyons c'est celle qui défend la valeur
travail le travail des classes moyennes
le travail des artisans le travail des
ouvriers
le travail des agriculteurs le travail
de ceux qui se donnent du mal et qui à
la fin du mois constate chaque année en
france qu'on gagne à peine plus en se
levant le matin qu'en restant c'est soir
parce que c'est cela la réalité de notre
pays
aujourd'hui celui qui travaille n'est
pas payée du fruit de ses efforts et ça
nous ne devons pas l'accepter
oui mes amis oui nous pouvons demander
des efforts aux français il y sont prêts
ils attendent simplement de nous que
nous remettions le travail au coeur de
la société française en 2017 ce sont ces
français qu'il faut entendre après cinq
ans d'un pot socialiste la droite doit
revaloriser les revenus du travail
nous voulons une chose qu à nouveau en
france travaillent et payent histoire
enfin reconnu la valeur travail
c'est la valeur de la droite française
alors il faudra du courage le courage de
dire qu'on ne peut pas continuer à avoir
des retraités qui ont travaillé toute
leur vie et qui finissent avec des
retraites de misère alors que dans le
même temps des étrangers qui arrivent
dans notre pays accède à notre sécurité
sociale sans même avoir cotisé
si on vient en france et pour travailler
et non pour profiter des prestations
sociales
le courage de dire françois comme tu
l'as fait qu'en matière de terrorisme le
laxisme c'est fini et que quand un
djihadiste par en syrie c'est un aller
sans retour
parce qu'ils n'ont plus rien à faire
dans un pays qu'elles ont trahi et le
courage enfants de ne plus rien céder
face à l'islam radical qui veut nous
dicter sa loi
nous défendrons nos racines toutes nos
racines
depuis les racines chrétiennes françois
jusqu'à celle de la révolution française
la france mes amis c'est une belle
histoire
la france est un grand pays et nous ne
renoncerons jamais à ce que nous sommes
ce n'est pas à la république de
s'adapter à celui qui vient de
l'étranger
c'est à l'étranger de s'adapter à la
république française et la dernière
condition de la victoire c'est celle que
vous montrez maintenant celle en vie
c'est la passion celle enthousiasme vous
êtes les républicains alors dressé vous
que votre voix résonne que notre
enthousiasme se lève et qu'il ne
s'arrête plus
jusqu'à ce que nous ayons ça c'est les
socialistes aient remis la france la
tête à l'endroit
tu es de la fin
elle doublera public
[Applaudissements]